[музика]
скандал самоїловий набір нового ви світу
україні завантажувачі знайти в раба чиня повік
ще з був на пари для вирішення проза
барона в'їзду російської встигати і
влади європейської модної спілки у ряду
україни сказано по шановно українські
закони про питання дізнається та зрозуміло
рішення ви б її дочка і виліпить verde в
1000 склад 23 березня
хоча у києві досі простого вода по
троянди sang теми до конкурсу лиж та вся
один місяць і самалова на їжу на
проблема києва з підготовкою євроремонт
лівобережній новий інтер'єр станьте іммо
трольєго дбайливо з шпильку розлучилася з
утихомириш 1000 кожного лама жий мільйон
доларів мало схожі на євроремонт
а не добуду б нападали комісій
виправдання міжнародного конкурсу
виставка вова центру 0 ккал та гостей
есенція обіцяє хват і за банером з
символікою конкурсу про ти поки що tigon
залишилося і завищуються не прибрані
ми та деки кіоски з шаурмою таємниць симів та
нападали до mpc ванни маятник ну тоді
перше травня
хоча на спраги і напевно петля
конкурсу повернути назад труднощами з
транспортом під'їзду dm bc приниження там
та учасником того steam конкурсу
можна б ти повинен і просто дистанція до
головного мого датчика євро батяня ніж
алана діян і не потрапляють новачків та
трамваї через дніпровон і мати курсу в
цей вид важеля вокзалу до магічної
послабить кай і ніби з штабними для
гостей європа чення про ті тисячі
проектів до ставте лайк там жити а до
початку конкурсу
вугілля дачі гаранта вати доки не беруться
pr пара динської
і в європейський місця я кавабата особиста
історія поїдуть зі страху і вас учасник
миска та голова києва Віталій Кличко за
минулого 100 євро baci не обіцяючи че
туристичний при треба то звучний
транспорт урологу пакет типу бачіли
радіан скайс мета океани на визнав і
свої місця і навіки зарубав і
альтернативно промо
[музика]
політизація конкурс європейського одягу за за
будинком організаторів сприйняття
примирення Європи на тому є пара
твориться на політичний інструмент
тарик москва дзвонова від олег і
про політизацію конкурсу через пісню
джамала продуктацію клієнт фіксатор і
конкурс завершився дуеллю Росії це
україни все говорити арена євро boccia
знову стала майдан чекам протистояння
і його москви і розрядка напруги вода
і найновіше українське каримо листя
телком піци лу
[музика]